もっと勉強したら経が楽になるのにと思う
ことてあるんですよ経営者としての
生きがいというものもここで見つけて
もらいたいと思って話をしました青木サの
人生経営哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話それでは青木タスの人生系鉄学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話無事にあの100は
終了いたしまして今回はスペシャル
バージョン大きさと指摘絶対に見てほしい
どうか5戦ということでお送りしていき
たいと思いますよろしくお願いいたします
改めて木さお疲れ様でございましたはい
ありがとうございます本当に感謝します
はいありがとうございましたはいここまで
のこう100話を振り返っていただいて
やっぱりこうまコメント欄とか通してです
ねたくさんのこう嬉しいコメントいただい
たかなという風に思うんですけれどもなん
かどんなコメントとかお声が多くありまし
たかまあでもすごくねまいつも見てますと
すごく勇気づけられますとかそれから私の
ね3日間の講座を出てそしてこの
チャンネルを見てくれて人も多いのであの
講座の内容で確認できたことをありますと
リアルな話にすごくためになりますとかま
そんなこと書いてくださってますよねうん
いや本当毎回見ていただいてる方もね
たくさんいらっしゃって本当にうんいや
本当にありがたいと思いますありがたい
限りですねあのま無事に100は終わり
まして100回聞いたら豊かになる話では
ありますので全部見ていただきたいていう
ところではあると思うんですけれども
なんか特にここまでのま100回分の中で
青木社長のおすめこれは是非見てください
というものをま5つあげていただくとし
たらというのを今日はちょっとお聞かせ
いただきたいなと思いますここに100話
分のあのリストがありますのではい
ありがとうございますすごいなよく話した
ねそうです
ね本当
[音楽]
にそうですね1番最後のねやっぱり豊かに
生きるためにっていうのはまず面白いこと
に最初と最後これはやっぱりどうしても
思いが入ってるよねだから最後の豊かに
生きるためにっていうのがまず100話目
だよねこれはま是非見てもらいたいそれ
からやっぱり第1話目の成功者と達成者の
最大の違いって何だろうってこれも一見
成功者と達成者って同じように捉えがちな
んだけど
ま私は若い時は達成者だったとでも成功者
ではなかったとそれは何がポイントかと
いうとやっぱり
目的そしてトータルバランスという概念
仕事の中に人生があるのか人生の中に仕事
があるのかとまこの辺はもう1回また見て
いただきたいと思うしあとはあのやっぱり
経営者の方に対してもねま
正直もっと勉強したら経が楽になるのにと
思うことってあるんですよだどうしても
勉強してもらいたいことえ第33話目かな
中小企業経営者として勉強した方が良い
ことこれはね是非見ていただきたいなと
いう風に思いますやっぱり56話目命
イコル時間と納得の行く人生を生きるため
のタイムマネジメント技術まこれは僕が
すごく大事にしていることなのでこれは
もう是非見ていただきたいと思います我々
あの無意識にね時間っていうものは命なん
だという認識を持たずにダラダラと時間を
過ごしちゃう人もいるんだけれどもこの
生きるということはこの時間というものを
能動的に自分の管理化に
そういう状態ってのはすごく望ましいわけ
でですからこの命の価値はまさに時間で
図ることができるわけででそうすると
やっぱりお金経済というものも豊かな方が
選択肢は広がるということになるので時間
の質が良くなるんですよねあとは70話目
の最高のパフォーマンスを発揮するための
休日の過ごし方とかねまこれも意外と仕事
仕事で生きてる人はやっぱりこう体しね体
壊しちゃったりいろんな意味で反動が来る
ケースがあるんでま私はやっぱり休日って
すごく大事にしてきたしま家族との時間
そういうものをすごく大事にしてきたと
えーあとえ81話目の経営者にしかでき
ない仕事は何かとこれもですね明日から私
は経営者なりますて言ったら大も経者に
なれるんですよ社長は誰でもなれるでも
明日から自分は医者になると言っても国家
資格取ってないと医者にはなれないという
ように経者ってなってから苦労が多いので
これだけはしっかりと経営者として抑え
といてくださいっていうことをまここでは
やっぱり伝えてるしまた生きがい経営者と
しての生きがいというものもここで見つけ
てもらいたいと思って話をしましたま
ちょっとプラスアルファもうちょっといい
ですか大丈夫ですうんどうぞそうすると
やっぱり93話目もいいと思うねメンバー
の主体性を引き出すために上司にできる
ことはま主体性を引き出すっていうのが実
は鍵なんですよねやらねばならないとねば
ならないという義務感でやってる人
やっぱりクオリティ質が低くなっちゃうの
で主体性があればあるほどこやりがいとか
働きがいが生まれてきますからまそういう
意味ではこの93話目はあの役に立つん
じゃないかなという風に思いますまあ
100はあるので全部ねえ私お勧めしたい
んですけれどま
あえて言うならばこのぐらいかなまだまだ
言いたいよね67のメンバーが察商人の
仕方とかねま上位に来たね投稿なんかも
結構めでについてのこととかもね話したい
ぐらいですけどまそのぐらいにしとき
ましょうかね
[音楽]
はいでもあの社長あの今回のまチョイスの
中には入らなかったですし動画のトップ
10とかにも入ってはないんですけどもあ
Xでめちゃくちゃバったやつもありました
ねあったねなんか700700万なんか
バったってねはいこXであんまりバった
ことないんだけど初めての験あれ正しさを
手放すという確か27話目ぐらいだったか
なそうですねそうですそうだよね27話目
27目の中の器の大きい人になるにはどう
したらいいかみたいなまそういうところが
なんかこうね注目されてバったみたいです
ねまでもやっぱり社会が今そういうま今
パワハラだとか色々やっぱりこう話題に
なってるけれどま結局正しさよりも楽しさ
局はねより良い人間関係を大切にできる人
が幸せな人生を手にしてるんじゃないかな
正しさ正しさで言っちゃったらみんなさき
まくって結果的に誰もついてこないと気が
ついたらなるべく観葉寛大やっぱり器の
大きな人になった方が良いということなん
ですよねそんなことこの27話では
てますので27番目の是非ねえこの投稿を
見ていただければと思いますえ今回一応
あの5戦ということで5つ選ぼうと思った
んですけれども8つ選んでしまいましたの
でこれ全部この後あの流しますので是非
楽しんでいただければと思いますまた
コメント欄にもね是非お願いします
チャンネル登録ももう是非ぜひよろしくお
願いしますえこれからも頑張ります
よろしくお願いします
青木サの人生系哲学100回聞いたら豊か
になる話早速ですが第1回目はえ成功者と
達成者の最大の違いは何かということに
ついて青木社長の系鉄学教えていただけれ
ばと思いますなるほど
[音楽]
この者も発生者も共通校はま物事を
成し遂げるということにおいては同じだと
思うんだよねでま能力とは何かと言うと
物事を成し遂げる力と僕は定義してるんだ
けどそういう意味においては成功者も達成
者も物事成し遂げるという意味においては
とても大切な能力だと思いますただその
成功とは
何かあのノアウェブスターという
アメリカの学問の知と言われるのは
ウェブスターがね成功とは探し求めた目標
の満足行く達成と定義しているのでただ
達成したら良いっていうんではないんだよ
ね満足行く達成これ非常に大事なテーマだ
と思うんですあのま僕は実は若い頃あの
プロのセールスの世界でトップセールスに
なトップマネージャーになり数々の書を
取ったんだけど実は若い時達成者だったん
だけど成功者ではなかったし幸せでも
なかった達成しても幸せではないでもま
人生色々こうキャリアを積んできてま成功
とは何かとさっきののはウェブスターの
定義にもあるようにじゃ僕は何を求めて
いるんだろう探し求めた目標の満足よく
達成だからから何を求めてるのかていうと
結局それはゴールではなくて
パーパス目的だっっていうことに気づいた
ん人生の目的は幸せになることなのでま
その何かを成し遂げても家族が1下離散だ
とか病気になってしまったり何かトータル
バランスという意味においてえ本当に求め
てる人生を手にできてない人もたくさん見
てきましただからやっぱり真の成功という
のは私は成し遂げるというだけではなくて
みんなにとって
望ましいトータルバランスという概念が
そこに求められてるんじゃないかなとま私
なりの捉え方ですけどねそんな風に思って
ますありがとうございますはい逆にその
達成者から成功者になんか変わってく
なんかポイントとかきっかけていうのあ
うんたりするんです
[音楽]
かそうですねま結局ねま成功者はキリの
ようにある一点に向かって働くということ
をよく昔からね言われるんですよまキリ
っていうのはこうバーってやって穴が開く
わけですよねでもそこには集中があるだ
から達成するということは当然のこと
ながら思考と行為をこの願望実現に向けて
集中しているので物事達成するんだけど
その時に周りを踏み台にしたりつまりえ
ウンルーズの状態なのかルーズウンの状態
なのかウンウンの状態なのかやっぱり大事
なことは共に勝つという考え方が僕は求め
られてると思うので若い時は勝ち負けでも
しょうがないんですよでもある年齢になっ
た時に共に歩む人のことも考えながら
やっぱりこう組織的に共に物事を成し遂げ
ていけるまそんな人生を僕は大切にしてき
ましたねま決して今自分自身成功してると
は思ってないこれはあくまでも僕は生涯
チャレンジャーだと思います成功というの
はあの他の人からの評価あの人が成功し
てるとか色々見られるかもしれないけど
ただ物事を成し遂げるっていうことに関し
ては私はとてもこだわってきたし全て
成し遂げてきたのは事実ですで今結局ま
会社であるたりま家族であったり私を
取り囲む人たちが幸せかどうかというのが
やっぱり真の成功という意味においては
大切なポイントかなと思いますけどねはい
ありがとうございますなんかウンウンと
いう言葉はすごくこう聞いてると綺麗敵だ
なと思うんですけれども一方でやっぱり
どこかそのウンルーズからウンウンになん
か切り替えていくっていうとちょっと違う
世界の話というかなんか綺麗事のように
聞こえることってすごくあると思うんです
けどなんかうんうんうんその青木社長自身
が切り替わったタイミングだったりですと
か逆にどうしたらそこってなんかウンウン
の方に視点を変えていけるのかっていうの
てありますかうんうんうんうん
[音楽]
これはねすごく良い質問だと思うんだけど
もあのスペシャリストって別に世のため人
のためになんだろう例えばアスリートにし
てもねま今世界で1番活躍してる日本人は
大谷翔平さんだと思うんですよま私もあの
大谷翔平さんのことをとても尊敬してます
ま花巻東高校のね立子夢実現プロジェクト
私たちも10年間サポートさせてもらって
ますけれども彼はでも日本のために野球し
てるわけじゃないよね自分の描いている
理想の姿やっぱり世界一の野球人になると
いうその理想が彼の中にあってでそれは
能力だけじゃなくてやっぱり人格的にも
こういう人間になりたいという彼の中にに
ある理想が結果的に周りの人に大きな感動
を与えそして彼のあり方やり方じゃだけ
じゃなくてあり方が彼のあの遺体な業績を
作り出してると私は捉えてるんですよで
やっぱり大谷翔平さんの死は佐々木浩さん
というま花巻東のえ公式野球部の監督なん
ですこの佐々木浩さんの教育価値観教育
ですよねこれが私はあの大谷翔平さんの
偉大な業績を作り出してると思いますだ
からそのま組織者としての成功ということ
とスペシャリストとしての成功これは
やはりちょっとまた捉え方が違うかもしれ
ないでも本質は一緒なんですけどやっぱり
自分のその求めてるものに対して周りの人
たちを決してですね踏み台にしない
やっぱり自分の求めてるものを得た時に
周りが素晴らしいとやっぱり賞賛して
くれる状態これが私は望ましいと思います
でうんだからスペシャリストの人たちま
アスリートにしても芸術家にしてもみんな
そうですけども自分の理想を追求して物心
両面の豊かな人生を手に入れている
で私は組織者としてまあ37年前に社員5
名資本金500万で会社スタートしました
まそして結果的に今おかげ様で社員も
200名になりそしてま会社はま
100億円以上の価値になりましたでも
それはお金を追ってきたわけじゃないん
ですよ大谷さんも絶対にお金を追ってあの
業績を出してるわけじゃないんですよ自分
の理想を追求した結果周りから見てその
価値にふさわしい評価で何百億という契約
金とかが生まれてくるわけで私もそうなん
ですよね自分の中でやっぱりこの仕事を
通してこういうことを成し遂げたいこう
やってみんなに喜んでもらいたいその思い
が結果的にま経済的にも精神的にも豊かに
なり自分の周りの人たちも豊かになると
いう現象が生まれてるわけですよだから
大事なことはやっぱりやり方も大事だけど
あり方そしてそのやっぱり目的じゃないか
なそこの目的を大切に
するぱパーパスっていうことでしょうね
ゴールはあくまでもその目的を
遂げるための通貨点でしかないんですよね
だからやっぱ目的に生きるっていうことは
キーワードだと思いますけどねうん
ありがとうございますはい最後にあの青木
社長まポイントは目的に生きることだって
いう風におっしゃっていただいたんです
けどなんか1日1日をその目的に生きて
いくために何かこう必要なこと大切にした
方がいいことこんなことした方がいいなと
かってあったりされれば教えてください
うんうん
うんまこれやっぱりパターン化するって
すごく大事なんだけど僕はあの1日のの刑
は朝にあると1年の軽は元旦にありって
よく言うじゃない僕は朝ものすごく大事に
してるのねで朝ってね実はね富の厳選と
言ってもいいぐらい朝の時間って重要なん
ですよ朝自分の人生をしっかりと考える
ことそして長期中期短期っていう風に
イメージしながら今日1日の積み重ねが
人生だから今日という日をいかに納得の
行く1日でするかってことなんね僕は必ず
朝自分の目的目標を確認するそして80対
20の法則というのがあるんだけど2割の
優先事項で8割の成果この2割の核となる
仕事自分の大切な職務をちゃんと
あらかじめ整理しといてそのことを1日の
スケジュールの中でいつやるかを決めるん
ですよそして毎日
必ず終わった時には振り返ることだから1
日のクオリティを高めることなくして人生
のクオリティを高めることはできない僕は
まさに成功とは満足した1日1日の
積み重ねであるとそんな風にも考えですね
朝へ起きてしっかりとプランニングして
悔いのない人生を頑張り
ましょうありがとうございますはい自分の
中に違いを許容できる器をのある人間に
なりたいという願望があるんだよね努力も
尊いけどもっと尊いものは正しい選択なん
ですよ瞬間式っていうのはね器のなさの
正明もうちっちゃいちっちゃい人間です
青木の
哲学100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね正しさの手放し方という
ことでお話しいただきたいと思うんです
けれどもま正しさを持ち続けるとまえ夫婦
だったりあるいはメンバーだったりま友達
だったりまいろんな人間関係を壊してま
パフォーマンスを下げてしまうということ
は分かってはいてもどうしてもなんか私が
正しいていうこう主張が全面に出てしまう
時にこの自分が持ってる正しさてのどうし
たら手放せるのかうんってことについて
教えていただけます
[音楽]
かまシンプルにまずその自分が求めている
ものは何かだよね要は勝ち負けで勝つこと
によって相手が悲しんだり自己概念が
下がったりそれからね一時的に自分が優越
感そこで勝つことによって何かを得て相手
との関係が壊れたりこれは本当に求めてる
ものじゃないでしょだからまずはそこを
よくよく自分自身冷静にまず考えた方が
いいよねだから僕は事実は1つだけど解釈
捉え方は生きてる人の数だけあるという
ことを選択異論という心理学で学んだん
ですよだから僕は人と争うことはしません
そういう捉え方もあるんだねあすごい参考
になった全く私と違う主張をしたとしても
なるほどあなたのバックグラウンドならば
そういう捉え方をするんだねとなるほどね
すごく参考になったという全てに対して
そういう姿勢ですでよく言われるんですよ
青木さんってなぜ怒らないんですかだって
そこで怒って何も得るものないじゃんうん
私はやっぱりそういう意味でま自分の中に
その違いを許容できる器をのある人間に
なりたいという願望があるんだよねだから
人はその人が考えている通りの人間になる
んで自分の中にそういうやっぱりこう許容
のできる器のある人間でありたいという
願望があればおそらく人の話をよく聞くと
いうことができるようになると思いますよ
うん青木社長は元々そのなんて言うん
でしょういろんな違いを許容できるなんか
怒ったりとかしないタイプだったんですか
うんそんなことないよ昔は俺はもう外的
コントロールマスターだよ大体ねプロ
セールスマネージャーの時代ね自分は
トップセールスマンだったじゃん結果出
ない人間ってやることやってないだけなん
だからやることやらせれば結果出ると思う
ので電話でアポトリーするって言って
なかなかアポ取らない人間がいるからジ機
持ってきてガムテープで参りやったでアポ
取れたらねご飯に行っていいよって言って
これひどいよね今の時代で言うとパハラ
でしょこれで昼になってそろそろ
マネージャーあの外していいですかって
言うからアポ取れたかいやまだ取れてませ
んいやお前ねアポ取ろうという気持ちが
内側から湧いてきたろ頑張れねでま2時
ぐらいになって腹減りましたもうアポ全然
取れないんですけど外していいですかだめ
だよ
アポ取ったら外しなそれよりな俺も一生に
飯食ってないんだよ俺に飯食わせてないっ
ていうこと知ってるかとかこういう外的
コントロール使ってたんですよ私はでそこ
で僕は自分の正しさその自分もご飯を食べ
ないんだ一緒になってそうやってやって
あげてるんだからこれは相手のためなんだ
ぐらいに思ってたわけよでもそうじゃない
のよやっぱりね体的なトークを教えてあげ
て何度もねそれをロールプレイングして
そしてお客さん役やってあげてで滑らかに
ちゃんと話せるようにしてあげることの方
がもっと効果的なのよニコニコしながら
それをやればいいわけで何度失敗しても
もう1回頑張ってみようてじゃあ今度は
もっとリストいいリストにしてみようか
って言ってやる方がい昔は電話帳ビって
破ってもう電話帳なんて今時ないでしょ昔
は電話帳だからこんな分厚い電話帳があっ
たわけ電話帳ビリッて破ってこれでアポ取
れってだから精神力はめちゃ強くなるんだ
けどまあんまり効果的ではないわなそう
いうことを経験しながらやっぱり非効率的
その効果的ではない行動の中からなん
だろう自分がそういうところを乗り越えて
きたから絶対精神力が身についたので
良いことだと思ってたわけよだから
スポーツの世界でもそうなんですよ昔
うさぎ飛びをしないとだめだそれから水は
飲んじゃいけないとか全く科学的ではない
ようなことを強制的にさせて先輩が後輩を
もう徹底的にしいたげてねそれでもやめ
ないやつをそのなんだ上に引き上げてく
みたいなやっぱそうじゃないやっぱりそう
じゃなくてもっと科学的にもっと効果的に
やっぱり努力も尊いけどもっと尊いものは
正しい選択なんですよだその選択の質を
上げるサポートをしてあげるそれがリード
マネジメントだと私は思ってだから昔は
批判する責める文句を言う神々言う脅すバ
する目先の褒美で釣るこれをやってたこと
があるんでも実際のところそれで人は育っ
たかって言うと関係が悪くなるだけで
決して良いことありませんでしたそして
選択理論と出会っても37年だけどね慶長
する支援する励ます信頼する需要する尊重
する意見の違いについて常に交渉する
そして一緒になってその本人の目的目標
達成願望実現を一緒になってサポートして
いくことの方が関係も強化されるしで外的
コントロールも使わない方がすごく楽しい
よねうんで私やっぱりま早く社会に出た
人間なので叩き上げの美学みたいの持って
たんだけどでもある時ねいやこれガミガミ
言ってるって器がない証拠だなとそして
学歴もなく家柄もなくね貧乏な家庭に育っ
てだからあの人はこんな風な表現するんだ
って思われるのは僕の理想とはかけ離れ
てるなと思ってねそういう家庭環境で育ち
いろんな経験をしたからこそあれだけ人間
が出来上がってるんだという風に言って
もらえる自分でありたいと思ってま選択
理論的なアプローチを実践できるように
なっていったってことかな例えばですけど
瞬間ゆか式みたいにその意見が違うものが
パンって上がってきた時には
て思っちゃってこのつい正しさを相手に目
の前でぶつけてしまうっていうこの瞬間
ゆかしみたいなタイプの人ってどうしたら
いいんですか
[音楽]
ねそれはあまり効果がないからやめた方が
いいねあのねなんだろううっていうのはね
自分の求めてるものと全く違うものが出て
きた時にうて一瞬こう感じるのはねこれは
しょうがないですよ生理反応だからから
その後だよねその自分に与えられた刺激に
対してすぐ反応するんではなくて刺激に
対して1回間を置いて自分で選択があ
るってことだよねそして伝えていく方が
いいだから僕はもう一切そういう瞬間
ゆかしになることないうん僕なんかあの
子供たちにねLINEで今日の予定どうと
か色々入れるじゃないですか全く既読に
なって返事が来ない時もあるじゃん
でも全然怒りを選択しないだって勝手に
LINEを送ったのは自分じゃないだから
そういう風にパラダイムシフトって言うん
だけどある1つの前提思い込みを変えた方
がいいうん人は自分とは違う自分の
思い通りには動かないんですよ瞬間式って
いうのはね器のなさの照明やって
ちっちゃいもうちっちゃいちっちゃい人間
ですもうカット来る人間ってなんかあまり
魅力的じゃないようんなんか差もかっこ
よく見えるんだけどちっちゃいうんだ僕は
喫茶店で例えばお水をバーンとこぼされた
とウェイトレスさんがそしてもあ大丈夫
大丈夫お水だから大丈夫心配しないで乾く
からもうそんな感じです配慮するタイプ
ですうんじゃあコーヒーだったら同じよう
に言えるのか洗濯台もらえばいいだけじゃ
んそうでしょでも大騒ぎはしちゃだめよ
ちょっとこれかかっちゃったねごめんね
あのこれちょっと選択に出したいので
ちょっと店長に言って洗濯台だきゃ出して
もらえますかって交渉すればいいだけ
でしょそれをね洗濯台ももらわずに帰って
きてブブブブ言ってそのお店の悪口を言
うっていうのは幸せになれない考え方です
うんだお金はちゃんともらった方がいいよ
それはなぜなら当然の結果というその責任
は取ってもらった方がいいんですよでも
そこでね辛い思いっていうかコーヒー
こぼされてね嫌な思いをしたのにそれ以上
に瞬間ゆかしみたいになって周りを気分
悪くさせたらもっと良くない結果になる
じゃんそれは僕は選ばない
[音楽]
うんま要はね事実は1つ解釈は無数そして
自分と人とは違う自分と未来は変えられる
他人と過去は変えられないもうシンプル
ですだから事実を事実として見てそれに
対しての捉え方は生きてる人の数だけある
という事実を認めるっていうことですだ
からなぜこの人はそういう捉え方をするの
か聞く方が楽しいじゃないこれパラダイム
シフトだよねうんそんなことを大切にして
もらうといいんじゃないかなと思いますよ
ありがとうございます是非ねえ今日学んだ
ことをえこのYouTube見ていただい
てる方はですねコメント欄に是非ねえ
どうぞ金入していただきたいなと思います
あの投稿をね楽しみにしてますあとは是非
ねえチャンネル登録も忘れないようにお
願いしますあの継続をして聞くことによっ
て見ることによって必ず豊かになる思考法
が身につきますのでよろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ますはいありがとうございますあ経者向け
の子だ息子さん来ますねそうそうそうそう
そうそうすごいですよね自分の父親が講師
やってる研修なんて絶対行きたくないと
思っちゃいますけど17回目だ
よすごいですねそっ
かいやでも1回も来いって言ってないから
ね娘に対してもうん一切強制したことが
ない
うんでもなんだろういついかなる時も僕は
宇宙1の理解者でありたいしいついかなる
時も僕は宇宙一の協力者であり
たいこれが僕の基本ですだからなんだろう
その愛
ってなんて言うのかな押しつけるものじゃ
ないしうんやっぱり本当に相手のことを
思ったら
喜んでもらえることをただただ祝しとやる
しかないんじゃないかなうんそんな風に
思うけどね本当そうだと思いますうんそれ
が1番難しいです
ねま少しキャリアがいるなそうですね
キャリアがいる年が必要かなといつも思っ
ますそうそうそういうもんだようん私もね
若い時からそんなねなんか出来上がった
ことをね今言ってるようだけど若い時は
そんな人間じゃない
本当いい加減なとこいっぱいあったもん
ただ1つだけ明確に言えることは若い時の
ノートにはこんな自分に勝つとかね約束を
守れる人間になれとかうんそういう叫びを
いっぱいノートに書いてたのは事実ですだ
から変わりたいという気持ちが根源的に
あったってことだよねこれでいいという
ことではなかったそれは間違い
うんやっぱりだから向上心はめちゃあった
と思いますうん今でもそうだもんねそう
でしょ69歳で大学院の俺学生だからいや
本当にいややっぱりなんだろうもっと良く
なりたいもっともっと良くなりたいもっと
もっともっともっと良くなりたいなんで
そんなに思うんです
かってわかんないそれはわかんないよでも
その気持ちが湧き上がってくるんだもん人
に同じように喜んでもらいたいもっと
もっとなんかできるんじゃないかなとか
うんこれYouTubeやるんでもそう
でしょ結局は受行性のフォローねともかく
受行性に良くなってもらいたい
うんその気持ちから全ての僕の行動は
生まれてくるわけですようんだから喜びが
伴うよねそこにはうんうんまそういうこと
だと思うけどな人の扱い方が天才的だと
言われたら間違いなく金の苦労はないです
僕は心理学を学ぶ時代が来てると思います
よ青木哲の人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる
話中小企業経営者として勉強すべきことに
ついて教えていただきたいと思いますま中
小企業経営者として成功したばこれだけは
勉強しろというものがまあるのかどうか
そして青木社長はそれをどんな風に勉強し
てこられたのかということについて是非
ですね教えていただきたいと思いますうん
これ心髄だよ
[音楽]
ね松下孝之さんの研究僕は長年してきたん
だけど孝之助さんはま経営者にとって1番
大切なことは何かという質問に対して自分
より優れた人間を使えるということですな
とそうそれだけで十分ですわとこうお答え
になってんだよねナポレオンヒルに成功の
研究を依頼したアンドリューカネギは己れ
よりも優れたものと共に働く技を持つもの
ここに眠るとま母familyに刻んだと
言われてますよね僕はやっぱり人を生かす
能力うん共に働く人をうん育成
しそして価値を想像し生きがい
やりがい働きがい
を作り出せる
能力うんやっぱり人なんですよ相手にし
てるものはお客様も人だし社員も人だしだ
から人の扱い方が天才的だと言われたら
間違いなく金の苦労はないです
でも人の扱い方が下手金の使い方が下手
物づくりが下手これは最悪の傾斜
ですだからやっぱり僕は心理学を
学ぶ時代が来てると思いますよ自分の経験
や職人のね叩き上げの経営者は自分が育て
られたように時代が変わってもZ世代の人
に対してゼネレーションギャップがあるの
に自分が根性論で育てられたからつって
根性論で行くとそしたらもうどん引きだよ
ねうん無能だとしか見えないですよ長時間
労働でねだから私なんか昔まブリタニカと
いう会社でセールスキャリアを積んで長
時間労働で確かに僕はタフな肉体持って
叩き上げでね営業で能力開発してきたです
よでも僕はうちの会社9日休みですよ
経団連にも入ってるし経済同友会当初の
議員企業でもあるうちはモデル企業を
目指してるんですよ分かったんですある時
に長時間働くことが悲しも高い
パフォーマンスを生み出さないや良い
仕組み良い人材良い
商品ちゃんと社会の求めに応じて適時
適切大切なものを大切にしてしっかりと
社会の求めに応じて努力していくことが
経営者としての責任だとま僕はやっぱり
採用には妥協がないし育成にも妥協はない
し営業マーケティングに関しても良いもの
を作ったら売るということに対しては
やっぱり情熱を持って熱意を持って
取り組むしうんこないだあのキーエンス
出身のねコンサルタントやってる人と
ちょっとある食事会で話したらすごく
キエスの文化とアチーブメントの文化って
あ通じるものがあるって言われましたよね
なんだろうやっぱり満足を追求してるので
ともかく満足を追求したいんですよもう
それだけなんですようんだ僕のこの気持ち
は全く淀みがない純粋な気持ちですねあと
やっぱり社員可愛いもん社員を豊かにし
たいよ絶対豊かにしたいよ精神的にも経済
的にもどこの会社でも入れる子たちが
アチーブメントを入ってきてくれたわけ
じゃん信じてトップライブって僕の
メッセージ聞い
てこの気持ちを裏切るわけにいかない
じゃんそしたら自精神が働くよね一生懸命
働くよね経営者自身のやっぱり姿勢が
変わるじゃないですかうんあとはやっぱり
価値ある商品を世の中に広めるルフする
そしてこの有向けの商品によって社会課題
を解決していくそこに本気で取り組むま
こういう考え方が経営者にとって必要だと
思いますよだからやな考え方持ってる経営
者はねもうM1Dでもしてねまともな経営
者にね会社譲った方がいいっていうぐらい
俺は思ってるなぜなら社員可いそうだもん
ぶっちゃけだって未来がないでしょ安月給
でこき使われ不満言われてうちの社員の
働きが悪いからうちは儲かんないふざけろ
とお前のせいじゃねえかと全部お前のせい
だよって俺いつも言ってあげてるよあなた
以外の責任者はいませんと要はなんだの人
のせいにしないでも最終的には僕が全責任
を持つそれが経営者なんですよただ現場の
実責任と異人責任は違うんだよね異人責任
からは逃れられないですよ経営者ってのは
いやもううちのね本当有料のね研修に来て
もらいたいわ本当うんそしたらね根本から
ね経営が変わるからいやマジにあのねなん
だろう儲からないのは社員のせいだという
考え方が貧乏哲学なんですこれこれ100
回聞いてもそういう考え方のし豊かなり
ません根本的に方めないと全部自分が
仕組み作ったんでしょってその仕組みの中
で働いてるのが社員ですよっ
てそういうことなんだよだから責任は経営
者にあるんですようんそういうことかなま
大体あの3日ぐらいかかるんでこれ話し
出すとこのぐらいにしときたいと思い
[音楽]
ますそしたら5つですね1つは採用と
育成採用する能力と育成する能力それから
営業とマーケティング能力そのうちは
すごい営業力もあるんですけど
マーケティング力っていうのは実はこれが
5つの中の商品力に関係してるんですよ
商品力が高ければ高いほど営業よりも
マーケティングつまり告知することによっ
てお客さん集まってきますよねでも最終的
には営業とマーケティング両方必要なん
ですよねでも本にいい商品を持てば営業は
カバーされますあとは財務管理
能力それから新規事業開発能力1つの仕事
で
ずっと永続的に稼ぎ続けることって難しい
ですが時代の変化がととにトヨタでも昔は
トヨタ防石からトヨタ自動車に変わった
ようにやっぱりですから社会のこの変化を
読み取りながら新規事業を常になきゃだめ
ですだM&Aも含まれるかもしれないよね
事業証券そして最後はやっぱり商品力技術
力だと思ううんまこの5つでもあえて言う
と本当は僕は1番大事なのは商品力だって
いう風に思ってんですよ商品力が1番
でしょうね次はやっぱり人材の採用と育成
力だと思うそしてま営業かな価値ある商品
そして営業力があるからお金の資金繰
りってほとんどしたことないぐらいもう
25年ぐらいお金の心配ない経営をしてる
わけでだそれはやっぱり本質にあるものは
まおそらくその商品イコールお客様満足に
対する異常な
こだわりあとはやっぱりまね新規事業の
開発それからま最終的には財務っていう
ことも当然お金をやっぱりきちっと管理し
ないとねダム経営しなきゃいけませんから
まうちもねそれないのもう資金がちゃんと
銀行にプールされている自己資本率も
70%というねまそういう系を目指し
ながらそれを本当にやりながら税引を利益
の3割は社員に還元する3割は未来のため
に内部留保するまた中に貯めるわけだよね
で3割は配当1割は社会に還元この仕組み
がねおそらくアチーブメントのある意味で
まあ発展を繁栄を作り上げてきたと思い
ますこの仕組みを作るのが警察ですこれは
ねあのまさにね有料級ですこれね
YouTubeでね見れた人は最高にね
ラッキーだと思います是非ねコメント欄に
えこの学びを是非書き込んでください
そしてチャンネル登録忘れないように
よろしくお願いします
[音楽]
青木社長から見てこの人勉強熱心だなとか
この人はうまくいくなってレベルで学ん
でる人っているんですかいるよ例えば湘南
美容の相川さんあの人も16回目でしょ
今回明日から来るよねまた
かず彼は学び続けてるよねで学んで実行し
て僕の伝えてる情報が確かだっていうこと
を確認するからさらに最熟をしてくわけだ
よ
だ最熟をしてく人ってのは事業が
ものすごく拡張してくよねだから果実なん
ですよあの繁栄っていうのはね自然の設備
なんだよねだから松下さんは生成発展の
法則と言ったんだけど繁栄が正しいんです
衰退は間違ってんです何か1人おりになっ
ちゃってんですまあ50期で僕は72歳な
のでその時にどこまで行ってるかま実際
50期だと300億ぐらいか
な経常利益は60億ぐらいの会社になっ
てると思い
ます僕は82になってるわけだよねその時
でもその時にもう相談役とかっていう立場
で私
は創業者というタイトルで講演するという
のが目標なんですよその時に社員に干渉
表しお客様に感謝を表しお取先に感謝を
表しま株主にも感謝を表わしでもそれが僕
は鉄構上
から溶接こ見習い
から人生スタートして結局学習の段階指導
力開発の段階朝鮮の
段階富の形成の段階社会加減の段階その
通りにになってるもんねだから本当にある
ナイチンエールの言葉人はその人が考えて
いる通りの人間になるこれは正しい
です間違いなく正しいうんやっぱりね曖昧
な思考からは曖昧な結果しか出ないんです
だから経営者で正直考えることを後回しに
する人は社長やめた方が
いいいや本当迷惑
ですめちゃ
迷惑ちゃんと成果から逆算して毎日生き
なきゃだめだようんそうしたら成果出るん
だからうんうちの会社絶対生果を社員全員
が共有してますから毎週月曜日必ず
メッセージしてるんで僕はとみんなが
パーパスにセットアップされてで各自
それぞれが目標を設定してで具体的なプラ
グに関しては上司がきっちり関わって
プランを立ててでKPIなんて社長が言わ
なくたって現場の人間全員KPIを考え
ながら実行してるんだもんそれは赤字に
なりようがないでしょそしてやりがい
生きがい働きがいをみんなが感じてだこれ
が僕が作り上げていこうとした組織体なん
ですよこれは今まだ200名はそこらの
組織だけどまあ500人ぐらいまでは
間違いなくこのままできると僕は思って
ます採用を間違わなければね今日という日
のクオリティは朝の段取りで決まると思う
何が1番大切なのかを熟に人生設計を
するってこなんですよ時の価値だよね人生
の中に仕事があるのか仕事の中に人生が
あるのか青き里の人生経営哲学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話
今回はですねあの以前の動画の中でも納得
の行く人生を生きることが大事だと青木
社長おっしゃられてたと思うんですけれど
もま命イコール時間だと考えた時に納得の
行く人生を生きるためにはまどんな風に
こうタイムマネジメントに取り組めば良い
のか青木社長が実際どんなタイム
マネジメントをしてこられたのかという
ことについてお聞かせいただけますかうん
うん
[音楽]
うんこれはテーマだよねあのねうんま結論
はね1日一生なんですよコントロール
できるのは今日だけなんだよただその今日
という日のクオリティは朝のやっぱり
段取りで決まると思うだから僕は1日と
いう単位のクオリティをいかに高めること
ができるかそういう意味ではままずは目的
をはっきりといつも自覚するってこだよね
目的が自分の時間のそのを使うことにそこ
に向かってれば納得の行く人生じゃない
やっぱりパーパス目的だと思うのよあとは
目的を明確にして何をいつまでに
成し遂げるのかということを決めるあの昔
本当にあっという間にも歳月が流れたんだ
けど37年前にチャールズホブスという
世界一のタイムマネジメントの
コンサルタントに私はアメリカでタイム
マネジメントを学びましたま当時世界一の
手長会社デイタイマーというね手長会社の
主席コンサルタントだったんですねその
チャールズホブスていう人はで私が
アメリカでえ研修受けた時に時間とは何か
ということに対して時間というのは出来事
の出現であるとチャールズホブスは言い
ましたでこの出来事を管理する技術これが
タムマネージメントだとでもその当時の僕
は時間って管理科におけるなんていう概念
なかったんですよどうやってじゃあ時間
管理するのかということで予測理論を使え
と予測理論つまり余地とか予報良き予測
未来に起こることをあらかじめ
想像して自分が求める人生に対しで戦略的
に今日を
生きるこれを僕はタイムマネジメントで
学んだんですよで今まで僕の人生に影響を
与えたね書物もちろん成功哲学だとかま
バイブルそしてチョイセオリーまいろんな
ものがあるんだけど私は今まで本当に多く
の様々なその学びの中で究極この自分の1
時間のバをいかに高めることができる
かっていうまさにこの時間の価値というの
はあの意図的に高めることができるという
ことを僕は学びましたそしてPF
ドラッカーというね計画者も言ってるんだ
けども結局その効果的に働くことこれが
やはり大切なことだとだから何も考えずに
とりあえず頑張るという一生懸命という命
を使う一生懸命ではなくて一生懸命でも
賢く明るい方の一生懸命やっぱり戦略的に
生きるってことだと思うんだよねまずわり
言っちゃうと人間はいつかは死ぬわけです
よその時に悔いのない人生を自分は生きた
と言いきれる人生を生きるっていうことが
正解なわけだからじゃあそれはどういう
ことかていうと僕は考えた時にまず大切人
大切なこと大切なもの何が1番大切なのか
を熟に人生設計をするってこなんですよだ
からま私はね今経営者を対象にしたあの
研修を長年やってきたりまたま能力開発の
おそらくまこの公開講座では今日本で最も
ロングランの講座を私は設計し30年間
やってきましたからそういうの経者も6万
人の受行生超えたんですけどもその中で
一貫して伝えてきたことはやっぱりこの時
の価値だよねだから人生の中に仕事がある
のか仕事の中に人生があるのか私は若い時
は仕事の中に人生がありましたでもある時
私は気がついたそれは人生の中に仕事を
置かなければいけないそうじゃないと
プライベートの面だとかトータルバランス
という面で考えた時に納得の行く悔のない
人生これを送ることはできないだろうと僕
は気づいた時にもう子供の運動会は先に
スケジュールを全部抑えました誕生日会
家族のイベント全部抑えましたそして本当
に大切なことを早く済ませてやりたいこと
のためにより多くの時間を作り出していく
今僕は来年ま呼を迎えるんだけどベスト
コンディションですよねそして私は今ま
本当におかげ様で富も得ました仕事をし
なくても一生困らないだけ罪はなしたわけ
ですよだけど僕は仕事が好きだからして
いるだ好きなことを好きな時に好きなだけ
できる人生って最高の人生なんだよもそう
するためには絶対に年代別の行き方を設計
しなきゃいけないだ僕は17から27まで
を学習の段階28から35までの段階を
指導力開発の段階35からえ45歳ここを
挑戦の段階で46から60歳までを富の
形成そして61歳以降は社会還元と名付け
てこの通りに来てきましたということは
いつこの間に幕を閉じたとしてもそれ悔い
がないってことですよねなぜならば計画し
てベストを尽くしてきたからでトップ
セールスになりトップマネージャーになり
トップコンサルタントになりでちっちゃい
ながら会社を創業し社員5名資本金
500万でしたで今おかげ様で素晴らしい
社員と共に220名の正社員ま従業255
名のこの組織を使いながらあと財団を僕は
やってますからもう4700人ね本当に
おかげ様でこの財団と共に日本の社会に
この選択理論アチーブメントテクノロジー
を広め不満足な人間関係が禁するあらゆる
不幸をこの世からなくしていくこの目的に
今は命を使ってるわけ
です先日ね本当にふと思ったんだよね縁
ある人の物心両面の豊かな人生の
想像本当に人の幸せのために貢献できる
人生って最高の人生だなだから僕は本当に
おかげ様で最高の人生を生きてると思い
ますうんついこないだねあの友人のね渡の
社長のね渡辺美さんとね2人でゴルフやっ
てただミキさんがねふっとねいやゴルフを
やってる時も仕事をやってる時もどっちも
同じぐらい楽しんだよねってポロっと言い
ましたあこの人は本当にやっぱり一流の
経営者だなとつまりねばならないじゃない
んですよ要するに命を楽しんでる存在を
楽しむこれはね大切なねポイントだと思い
ますね私はそうやって懸命に生きてきた
そんな人生ですありがとうございます特に
経営者の方であればタイムマネジメントに
おいてまここを大切にすべきとかっていう
ポイントってありますかまそれはね
シンプリに努力よりも正しい選択を優先
するってこですだから出しちゃいけない
場所に見出してその後えらい苦労するとか
採用しちゃいけない人間採用してめっちゃ
後に秘し作業みたいに苦労するとかだから
やっぱり正しい選択が成功のまずり8割は
決定すると思うよ2割は別の要素だと思う
でも選択は本当に重要だ経営者は選択に
焦点を当てるだから戦略的に考える時間を
後回しにしないってことです
[音楽]
ね1年の計は簡単にあるんですよ1日の計
は朝にあるんですよ必ず毎朝自分の1日を
納得のいく1日を過ごせるように設計する
ことですそして物事はね2割の優先事項で
8割の成果なの
でこの2割の優先事項をきちっと実行する
時を決めて毎日必ず実行してくださいそし
たら経営であろうと営業であろうとどんな
分野であろうと必ず成功しますこの1日の
コントロールこれが1番人生で大切なこと
だということですえ是非ねあの今日の私の
メッセージを聞いていただいた方はですね
チャンネル登録をしてくださいそして
コメントもお忘れなくよろしくお願いし
ます人間として承認してあげるんですよ
全面承認しますだ承認っていうのは指導者
の人間感が出るんです認められたい
でしょってなら人のことも認めてあげ
なさいよ青木サの人生経営哲学100回
聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はえ承認することが大切とよく聞き
ますがなぜ承認することが必要でまどんな
時に青木社長は人を承認されてらっしゃる
のかということについてお聞かせいただき
たいと思いますなるほど
[音楽]
こんなの当たり前の話なんだよ僕はね
100%いつも承認してるよだって存在
自体が素晴らしいじゃんあのこれ面白いね
うちの子供達てねあの一応市学に小学受験
で入れたんだけど本当勉強しなかったのだ
けど私の大事な子供であるという存在は
変わらないじゃんだから全証人ですよ確か
にねそこそこのね成績でした
よだけどだよいいじゃん僕は言ったよね
うちの息子にでも勉強は面白くないよなと
勉強嫌いなの分かるよっってだって勉強
って面白くないもんてお父さんだって勉強
あんまり好きじゃなかったうんよくわかる
よただな大使な大事なこと言うよ勉強でき
ないとお前思ってんじゃないかうんそう
じゃない勉強してないだけだ分かるかすれ
ばできるんだこういう考えだからでなんで
勉強しないかったら面白くないかなんでだ
と思ういいかそれはなお前のせいじゃない
んだよ先生の教え方が悪いんだつ分かる
これこれ偉い打席にしてるように感じる
でしょ実際そうだもん事実じゃんそれ先生
教え方下手だよだって俺自分自身長年研修
やってきたけど僕の研修寝る人いないもん
もうね私が作ったその3日間の願望実現
目標達成の研修プログラムま今私の弟子が
全部研修やってるけれどそれでももうのべ
新規6万人以上受けてるわけだからこの人
たち誰も寝ないです
よなんで面白いからだよどうして面白いの
自分のために受けてるからだ
よこのセットアップが先生できないんだ
もんそうでしょ何のために勉強するの将来
どうなっていきたいの
パーパスだよ目的のセットアップができ
ないでただま立場で勉強しろ勉強しろと
これ親も先生もそういう
指導だから内発的な同期けって起きないん
ですよだ今のその承認のテーマだけど人間
として承認してあげるんです
よ全面承認します私は我が子にとって宇宙
の理解者
です娘にとっても息子にとって
も宇宙1の理解者です私はうちの家内に
対してもそうです不足感全くありません
感謝だけですだこういう考え方が大事なん
だよねうん社員もそうです220人の社員
本当に宝
ですだここが足りないあそこが足りない
もっとこうした方がいいああした方がいい
もちろん改善って必要だよねならそれは
事実問題として人間としては承認しながら
していることの改善は促せばいいじゃんだ
私は自分の子供に対しても勉強せざる得
ない環境は整えてあげたよ海外留学して
全く英語できないのに海外に留学して見事
2人とも良い成績でね卒業してくれ
やっぱり能しながらそれはやっぱり小さい
時から自己概念は下げてないので全面承認
してるから自己概念めちゃ高いんですよ
自己概念が高いってことはやればでき
るって思い込んでるってことなんですよ
分かる自己概念が低いってことはやっても
できないと思ってるわけですよそれは指導
者が暗示かけたからです不足感を植えつけ
たからです私は違います僕はもう社員に
対してもできると思ってるなんだろう愛な
んだ
よだ証人っていうの
は指導者の人間感が出るん
ですうんだから器のないやつって人を認め
られないんだってともかく偉そうにする
じゃんだ俺偉そうにしてるやつで偉いやは
いないと思ってんのよいや本当いないよ偉
そうにしてるやつ偉いやつに会ったこと
あるかもう偉いそうにしてるってこと自体
がどんな社会的な地位があろうとそれが
どうしたのってな話だよま本当にねなん
だろう早くから社会に出て俺の知り合いで
もいますよ一生懸命頑張って家族のために
生きてる人
が社会的にはそれほどのポジションじゃ
ないうんいいじゃないですだけど立派な
父親です
よ生き様が素晴らしいこれでいいんじゃ
ないのほらだからまたほらこの友人にも俺
は承認してるじゃんも分かるこの
さりげなくう言葉の中に証人が全部出てく
んだようんうちの役員の橋本拓也が青木
社長のマネージメントって一言で言うと
証人ですねでポロっと数年前にったけどあ
確かにそうだろうなってうん僕は承認して
ます認め
るってことですバイブルにはね何事でも
人々からして欲しいと望む通りのことを
人々にもそのようにせよとあるんです
よ相手の発することをね自分がしてもらい
たい
ことそれを相手にもそのまましてあげたら
いいじゃないですか
認められたいでしょってなら人のことも
認めてあげなさいとでも僕は無意識にやっ
てんだけどねもうそういうあの計算も何に
もないのでだからま本当にね社員大好きだ
し仕事大好きだしお客様大好きだしだから
喜んでもらいたいと思ってるそういう真心
を持って仕事をしていたらうまくいって
当たり前だよねうんそういうことじゃない
かなうんありがとうございます承認し慣れ
てないとどうしてもこう意識してまず承認
するっていうところからスタートすると
思うんですねでそうするとついなんか
100%承認すると相手を甘やかしちゃう
んじゃないかっていう気持ちとすごい戦う
ことになってしまう気がするんですけれど
もそれってどうやって乗り越えたらいい
ん甘やかすという言葉をどういう風に
捉えるかなんだけれども責任が人間に育て
てしまうんじゃないかともしそういう風に
思うとしたらそうではない承認をしながら
責任は取らせるんです例えばね子供で言う
ならば答えは自分の中にあるという風に僕
は育ててきました自分の頭で考え
て行動して全責任を取りなさいとだ僕は
答えを教える親じゃないのよ答えを自分で
見つけさせる教育をする親なんですよこの
方が厳しいよだって自分の選択に責任を
持たなきゃいけないんだもんそう思わない
ほないっから厳しくしてガガ言って責任は
全部親が取る上司が
取る指導的立場にある人間が全ての責任を
取って本人は神々言われりゃ
頭の上が嵐が過ぎたら終わりみたいな厳し
いっていう言葉の定義を変えた方がいいと
思う厳しいっていうのは誰かが誰かに対し
て失跡することや外からのね外発ま批判し
たり責めたり文句言ったりがね脅したり
そういう外発を与えて本人に責任を取ら
せるもしくは何かをその自分が好ましく
ないと思った状態をコントロールしようと
してそういう風に本人にこう苦痛を与え
ながら苦痛から開会への移行って言うんだ
けどね専門的に言うとこれを起こさせよう
として変えよう変えようとこれはね証人と
はまるっきり逆の世界なんだけどあのなん
だろう責任を回避する人間が育ちますで僕
ね色々研究したんだけど嘘を言う人言い訳
っていう人の本質にあるものは恐れですだ
から恐れ
をマネジメントに使うということは責任
逃れをする人間が育つんですよこれすごい
深い話なんですでも全責任を本人に持たせ
たら逃れられないよね自分の中に答えを
出すその答えって目的
目標計画日々の実践一貫性を通していく
生き方をしていくわけですから当然成果
からは逃れられないわけですま私はそう
いう育て方をま我が子にも社員にもして
ますけど
[音楽]
ねまず存在を全てまず受け入れるっていう
ことですねうんもう存在そののに価値があ
るってことですこれがまず第1で2つ目は
その本人の選択の質に関しては完璧完全な
選択ってできないじゃないですかだから
ベストを尽くしているようわけですから
最善改善に導いていってでより望ましい
成果に対して自分の近も使い
ながら最大のサポートをしてあげながら
達成に導いてあげることその間はま心理的
安全性だとかなんだろう安心安全な空間を
与えてあげてそして目的目標達成に導いて
あげることま証人というのは存在そのもの
を受け入れると定義したら良いんではない
かと思いますそれと仕事のやり方や技能
知識の不足それは別の問題だからそれは
それでしっかりと計画を立ててマインド
ノウハウスキルを総合的に高めてあげる
ことこれはやっぱりまた指導者の責任では
ないかなと思いますねま短い時間です
けれどもあのやっぱり1番大事なことって
何かって言うとまさっき言った黄金率成功
のマスターキーですよねあの成功できない
人って基本的にはり
高ぶり人のことを認めれないので優れた人
と共に働く技術がないんですよやっぱり
偉大なことを成し遂げてる人は自分の周り
に優秀なスタッフをきちっと集めることが
できてますそれはね前提として証人人を
認めるっていう心があるから
こそ人が協力者になってくれるとまこう
いうことだと思いますま是非チャンネル
登録もよろしくお願いし
ます体のベストコンデションはプロの基本
体なので僕はメンテナンスに投資をするし
良い会社って社員が働き者なんですよ大切
な人大切なもの大切なことに時間を使うと
いうのが賢さじゃん青木サの人生経営哲学
100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回は最高のパフォーマンスを発揮する
ための休日の過ごし方ということでま青木
社長年齢と共にこう休日の過ごし方って
いうのをま最高のパフォーマンスを出す
べく変えてこられたのかですとかあるいは
なんかちょっと息抜きをしてる時になんか
仕事をしなくていいのかなみたいな不安に
襲われたことないのかなですとかちょっと
休日の過ごし方ということについてお聞か
せいただきたいと思い
[音楽]
ますま基本的には子供がいない時子供が
できた後そして子供が成長してもう
え海外にま高校から2人とももう留学させ
ましたので実は私の休日の過ごし方って
プライオリティの第1は家族ですよね家族
との時間を中心に考えてきましたでま今は
あまり相手にさえなくなったからねもう
2人とも成人してだから僕なりの休日の
過ごし方ができるようになった
でもま若い時ま若い時は休日っていう概念
がないよねだから時間の長さで買って仕事
の量で買って密度で勝つっていうのが私の
若い頃からのMODだったからもうまさに
ワーカーホリックですからはいもうその
ワーカホリック何かってのもんでねうん
なんか好きなことやってて何が悪いんだっ
てだ俺逆に言うと遊びばっかりやってる
やつてバカじゃねえかなとなんでこんな
遊んでばっかり言ってね将来どうなんだと
貧乏になるぞといやぶっちゃけそう思って
たもんねまず俺は貧乏な家庭で育って早く
社会出て何にもないわけじゃん最初は鉄構
所からスタートしてプロの営業の世界に
入ってなら
まずキングダムのわらべ真だよ大将軍なる
ぞってまず大将軍なんなきゃなんか
ちょっと激ようになってきたけどいや本当
休日なんだまず若い時はありません
はっきり言ってというのは必要ないんだよ
そんなもんは必要ないんだで僕は老朽法に
縛られて生きてないから人生もうフル
コミッションですからはいもう個人事業者
なのでいやだからいや俺から言わせると
企業という枠組の中に入れられて自分の
能力開発ができない人間になったら終わり
だよと逆に企業の枠で働いてで労働時間が
コントロールされるなら残った時間は全部
自己啓発しなさいといやそれぐらいの思い
ですよね20代30代でその後の40代
以降の人生決まります20代30代
ボケボケしてるやつは40代50代も
ボケボケだよ俺からはそれはっきり言って
やばいな過激発言いやマジ本音言っちゃう
とそういうことうんだからまうちの子供が
できたのがやっぱりま結婚もね遅かったの
であのまある程度自分なりにそれなりの
経験を積んで富の厳選となる知るわかる
行うできる分かち合うという能力活の5
段階の中の知るわかる行うできるこの
できるというレベルまでまず自分自身を
鍛えて能力開発をした後なのでただ当時金
が全然なくてあの会社創業した直後ねま
うちのかとも結婚し会社を作ったばかりで
資本金500万社員505人で創業した
わけですけれども最初はやっぱりま相
変わらずイツワークアン枠ですよま社長業
っていうのはまさに老朽法関係ないからね
だけどま娘が生まれてきたすとま夫婦で力
を合わせて育てましたよねうんだからま
日曜日は午前中はま教会に行って午後は
家族との時間とすると仕事はしないように
心がけましたでもね苦しいじゃん経が
うまくいかないんだから最初創業した直後
はうんやっぱり仕事してたよねていうのは
誰かお客様と会っていたりそのメとま食事
をしたりとかあのま食事っていうかお茶
飲むとか夜は絶対家族の時間だから
ちょっとしたあのなんだろう午後出かけ
たりしてたことはあったと完璧に休日にし
ていたわけではないただだんだんそれが
ある程度余裕ができてきたらあのもう完璧
にそこはコントロールしましたよねあとは
子供の運動会は全回出席ですから私はだ
から誕生日とか子供の日とか子供の誕生日
ねもちろんそれからえ学校の運動会
いろんなその学芸会とか色々あるじゃない
そういうことはスケジュールの中に
あらかじめもうきちっと取っといてでそこ
はもう必ず大切にあの優先するようにし
ましたよねまこれだから間に合ったって
感じかなつまり若い時に多分結婚してたら
全く僕は多分それができなかったと思う
なぜな自分作りが先だからだからなるべく
自分という人間を作った後から結婚すると
か子供作る方が僕はいいという風に自論で
は思ってますよねそんな感じかなだから
家族中心の休日の過ごし方をしてきたでま
あえて言うなら最近はどうなのって言っ
たらメンテナンスだよね非常に僕は
メンテナンスに投資をするし体のベスト
コンディションはプロの基本体なのであと
はま川口湖に別荘があったりしますから
あの別荘で休日は過ごしたりそれからま
昨日あった友人が川口湖の方にもいたり
するのでえそれこそあの渡海のね渡辺さん
ともうゴルフシーズンは2人でゴルフやっ
てるねそういう過ごし方をしてますよね
やっぱりね抜くっていうのも大事なのよ私
の年齢になってきたら頭では働いてる
けれど体で働くわけでは
ないでやっぱり異人の技術を今使っている
ので220人社員がいてね未だに私はなん
だろう体で稼いでますって言ったらこれ
無能でしょいや本当にえそういうことなん
だよだから最初は率先炊なんだよだけど
あるところから社員を働き者にできる企業
体にしなきゃだめだと思うよ良い会社って
社員が働き者なんですよでもまだその
レベルじゃない会社は社長だけが働き者な
んですよだから働きもんだっていうことに
酔わない方がいいようんそれは社員を
もっと大切にしたらいいこの意味わかる
守られた水は腐るんですよ魚を与えたら
また魚が欲しいってなるじゃんだ釣り方を
見抜けさせてあげるんですそうすると自分
が釣らなくても良くなるじゃんそうすると
自分はゆり時間が生まれてくるからその
ゆり時間から休日の過ごし方が変わるわけ
よ今僕あのキャンピングカー買ったのね
はいこれ結構いいやつなんですよあの
ハイマーというね割とヨーロッパのいい
キャンピングカーなだけどこれでうちの奥
さんと一緒にあの休日は色々旅をしようと
思ってますよあとあの全国に60の今日本
プロスピーカー協会の支部があるのでこの
支部をこのキャンピングカーで回
るっていうのが今ねちょっと将来的な
楽しみに思ってるわけでみんな喜んで
くれるかなと僕はキャンピングカーで回っ
たらそん時はねYouTubeでね
キャンピングカーのね僕と一緒に同して
もらってね是非あの楽しんでお願いしたい
なと思ってますんでよろしくお願いします
はいま休日の過ごし方はそんな感じ
ありがとうございます本当に最初はIT
ワークアワーでま休日なかったって
おしゃられていたくらい働かれて働かれて
いたところからやっぱりこう少しずつ休日
をその家族中心に切り替えていかれた時に
なんて言うんでしょう大丈夫かなみたいな
不安感だったりですとかそういうなんか
その休日を取ることに対する後ろめたさ
みたいなものってなかったんです
[音楽]
かないの俺の人生だもん何かみたいなもん
だようんだって大切な人大切なこと大切な
もの大切なことに時間を使うっというのが
賢さじゃん俺やっぱり家族すごい自分の
願望にあるよね子供の時にちょっとやっぱ
寂しい家庭環境だったから僕は社員もそう
だけどま家族が社員大切な友人がうちの
受行性で自行生の中でもしっかり学んで
くれてる4700人の日本プロスピーカー
協会この財団のメンバーまそういう人たち
のことを願望のど真ん中に僕は入れてるの
でそういう人ととに過ごす時間は
クオリティタイムだと思いますよだから
休日っていう概念って休む日でしょその休
みって遊んでる時も働いてる時も好きな
ことをしてるんだったらそれは休みじゃん
好きなことを好きな時に好きなだけできる
人生これ
が究極なんじゃないのいやだから俺本当
正直今1番関心があることってだから健康
管理しないとこれからさ現役まだまだ
バリバリでやってこうと思ってるのにだっ
て1番楽しいことって経営することじゃ
んだ俺本当正直本当のこと言おう
かスターウォーズのようなあのよだって
いるじゃん俺ヨだみたいになってフォース
使って何百年ももし生きれるならだよ
ずっとこのアチーブメントグループの警し
ていいよすげえ会社になると思います
はっきり言って残念ながら有限なんだよだ
から誰を後継者にするか高校にやっぱり
時間を取るし考えてるし仕組みを整えて
いくし有限なんだよ僕の人生もあとね
どんなに気合入れてもさ本当に現役って
言ったらあと10年が1番
華々しい10年だと思いますよえまだ
あなた10年華々しくと思ってんのって
思うかもしれないけど大体ね年齢ってね
カレンダー年齢と魂年齢違うんだよ魂年
取らないんだよ未だに僕は若いですよ何か
みたいなもんだよいや本当にうんやっぱり
人生は楽しま
[音楽]
なきゃま日常生活が大事なんじゃないの
栄養きちっと取る
ちゃんと睡眠を取ること適度な運動する
ことねそして物の考え方をネガティブに
考えない常にポジティブに人生を楽しむ
そして大切な人と大切なこと大切な時を
優先するそれがベストコンディション充実
した休日を過ごすことじゃないかなうん僕
あの車が好きでね何台も持ってるんだけど
ま車もよく休日はね乗りますしねま
ともかくね楽しいことしたらいいようん
休日はあなたのものです誰のものでもない
ですはい楽しんでくださいえ是非ね
コメント欄にもコメントよろしくお願いし
ますまおそらくあなた変わってるねとかね
思われると思いますけどもま変わってるん
です私はね自覚してますからま是非あの
これからもねえチャンネル登録もして
いただいて仲良くやっていきましょう
よろしくお願いします価値を想像していく
クリエイターであるということだと思うん
だよね経営っていうのは究極決断と実行
その決断の質というものがすごく重要で
青木サの人生経営哲学100回聞いたら
豊かになる
話経営者にしかできない仕事は何ですかと
いうことでま経営者にしかできない仕事ま
一方でうん部や社員に任せられる仕事って
あると思うんですけれどもこれそれぞれの
どんな仕事なのかっていうことについて
教えていただけますかうんなるほど
[音楽]
そうですねまず経営者っていうのは同じ
経営者でも創業者とま従業員処刑してきた
経営者とはまたちょっと違うかもしれない
んだけれどもえ創業者の場合は創業の思
いっていうのがあると思うんですよねま私
の場合はうちの社員と決定的な違いって何
だろうっていう風に思うとこの会社の存在
理由目的に対しての明確な答えを自分が
まず持ってそして価値を想像していくま
クリエイターであるっていうことだと思う
んだよねだからま無はUの原点という言葉
があるんだけどもあくまでも僕のこう
アイディア思考の中から
経営というのはなされていくわけですよだ
からしていいことしなければならないこと
そういう1つの価値観明確な判断基準の
土台にあるま1つの社員がこれはして良い
これはしてはダメだっていうようなま
ルールにしろ起立にしろその元となる文化
を作り出していくまたしっかりとそういう
人が育つ文化を作るというのはやっぱり私
は経営者の責任ではないかという風に思い
ますよねま経営っていうのは究極決断と
実行そして決断に対しては責任が伴います
よねだから決断する仕事ともう1つは責を
取る仕事これは他の社員にはできない
でしょあ2代目3も同じなんだけれども
経営者になるっていうことは決断できる
人間を育て
るっていうことその決断に全責任を取れる
人間を育てるその決断がだねポイントは
利己的であったり本質的長期的客観的な
視点に立った決断ができないで利己的で
戦略的で目先の今さえ良ければ良いという
ようなそういうその決断しかできなかっ
たりあとあの私は損して得れどっちかって
言と損か得かって言うと目先人から見たら
損な決断をたくさんしてきましたおそらく
これはま例えば昔の横綱千代の富士の引退
記念のプログラムを作った時
1億5000万の当時は不良在庫なんだ
けどその在庫を全部引き取るとこれは私に
しかできなかったことだと思いますなぜ
ならそれを引き取るっていうことは倒産の
リスクを引き込むわけよなぜその時にそう
いう意思決定ができたかって言うと
やっぱり相手の立場に立ってこれは自分が
お願いしたことだとやっぱり責任を取
るってことだよねその決断の質というもの
がすごく重要で尊徳でものを考えない
もっと言うたら長期的ま人間ってみんな
利己主義なんだけど狭いところでの協議の
利己主義なのか講義の利己主義なのか
やっぱり経営者っていうのは長い目で見て
意思決定できる人間じゃないかなっていう
風に思うよね働く人の中でも長期的な視点
に立って本当にこれが会社のために良い
ことだと思えることができる人って幹部に
なってきますよねなかなか難しいよねこれ
はやっぱり自分の小心昇格だとか自分の
優先順位とかって考えた時に後回し
に今今期の成績にならないから断ろうとか
そうなっちゃうんじゃないかと思うんだよ
ねでもそれはその上の役員が見てていや
ちょっと待てとこれはこんな風に編成を
変えててもやろうとまず入り口作ろうとで
これやっぱり5年で物にしようとかだから
投資の意思決定ってのはやっぱり経営者
ですよね特に私の場合は47歳の時に新卒
の採用をするって決めましたよねだ僕は
正直ねその自分でこう決断する時って自分
で決断してんですよだからみなが第した
からやるっていうんじゃないんだよね深層
採用やるってでも反対が出ましたよそこに
ね深層作用にそれだけの多額のお金を
かけるなら今いる人材にもっと分配して
欲しいとかうんまそれやめちゃったやつだ
けどでも僕はやっぱりそれ踏み切ったうん
それから選択理論というものを土台とした
商品開発を
するこれ普通選択理論を元にした高品質の
人材教育という風に言ってもなかなか目に
見えないものでお金にするって大変なん
ですよそうすると安易にもう形があるある
程度ブランドのしっかりした会社の商品を
扱った方がいいんじゃないかとかそれとか
そうねま世界的にやっぱりこう有名なもう
ナンバーワンとも言えるセミナー
の日本の窓口にならないかっていう話が
あった時僕は断ったんだよねでなんで
かって言うとそのなんだろうもうすでに
十分著名なその十分世の中に広まっている
ものを今更俺がやってもしょうがない
だろうな
とだから時代の頭をね誰かが言ったよね
そのチャンスの神様って前髪しかないと前
から来たとこパッとつまなきゃだめだと
後ろ行ったらもう後ろは全然髪の毛ないと
やっぱりこう儲かっている有名だブランド
があるすごい世の中に広まってい
るっていうことはもう後ろ髪でしょそんな
中今更参入してもしょうがないじゃないか
とだこれも多分僕はそういう意思決定した
けど普通はブランドがあるからって言って
それを取りに行くと思うんだよだから
儲ける儲からないじゃないんだわ実はこれ
僕はやっぱり経営者としてちょっと違う
意思決定してますよね選択理論を日本の
メジャーにするていうことも今
ウェルビングというねこの社員を幸せに
できる
経営社会を幸せに導いていくそういう経営
がまさにその英理主義ではなくまSD
ジーズのような取り組みをする会社に若い
人が入りたいという時代が来てるけれども
でも人時代前まではそういうことってお金
にならないよねで切り捨てられてた私はお
金にならないことを選んで独占的にその
市場を大きくしてきてるですよそれで私の
公開口座をぜ設計した公開口座を全部学ん
だ人たちだけが入れる財団まで作ってま
これ今4700人ですけどこれを1万人ま
将来は10万人にもしたいと思ってるんだ
よねでも小さな本体で大きなプロフィット
を満たせるこれどこからこの意思決定き
てるかっていうとナポレオンヒルの成功
哲学なんですよマスターマインドって考え
なんですよでアンドリーカーネギーていう
鉄鉱はナポレオンヒルに20数年に及ぶ
この成功の研究を依頼したんだけどその
当時の大富豪鉄鉱アンドリューカーネギー
は1回の鉄工書の行員から身を起こして今
の時代でいう13兆円の罪を気づいたん
ですよでこの13兆円の罪っていうのは
すごいと思いますよねでもその
アンドリューカネギが1番大事にした言葉
って己れより優れたものと共に
働く技を持つもの子に眠ると母
familyに刻んだとここに僕は経営の
行定があると思ったのだから私は己れより
優れた人例えばうちの顧問の1人は全中小
教庁の長官の前田泰博さんで
あり北大の今AIの日本のもう3本の指に
入る研究者である川村教授だとか一流の人
たちを顧問に迎えてるよねそれから
4700人の財団のメンバーこれ各地域で
みんな名刺って言われる人たちもいっぱい
入ってるまそん中から2人市長になってる
わけでしょでも県議会議員だといろんな人
も出てきてるけれどでも別に僕は政治に
対して云々んじゃないのねやっぱり松下
孝之助さんだって松下政経塾をお作りに
なって国のために尽くしてるようにま僕
自身もやっぱりこの小さな本体だけど
大きな社会貢献小さな会社で大きな社会
貢献をするにはやっぱり僕は教育者の教育
をするこういう事業が大事だと僕は思っ
てるわけよってことは経の目的は私の思考
から生まれてるよねこれはだから私の会社
の文化の元だと思います
[音楽]
よまだから決断するっていうことと責任取
るってことでしょそういうことだと思い
ますようんそのためにはやっぱり自分を
高めてかなきゃねだから目先の尊徳で意思
決定しないことうん本質的長期的客観的な
視点で意思決定した方がいいです私の講座
毎月300人400人来るんですよこれ
勉強に今回YouTube見てる人ね無料
ですからねお得ですいや本当大事なことな
のようんだから私はアチーブメント
ピラミッドの一貫性ってことを教えてき
てるんだけどやっぱり理念を作りビジョン
をしっかりと策定して目標設定計画日々の
実践ここに一貫性を通すっていうことそれ
を経営者は人生理念作りから始めなさいと
まず個人のピラミッドを作ってあとは会社
のピラミッドを作ってで一貫性を通す決断
と実行そして全責任を得まそういうことだ
と思いますよろしいでしょうか
前向きな願望だけに焦点当てるんではなく
てどういう自分でありたいのか本人に
プランを考えてもらうま要は考えさせ
るってことだよね自ら考え自ら行動した
ことには責任が伴うのでそれは人を育てる
ことになるんですよ青木サの人生経営哲学
100回聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですねの人っていると思うんです
よなんか上司に言われたからとか会社に
言われたからとか親に言われたからどうこ
ていう方っていらっしゃると思うんです
けれどもまそういったですね受け身では
なくてこう主体性を引き出していくために
逆にその上司としてできることて何
でしょうかっていうところをお聞かせ
いただきたいなと思っております
[音楽]
うん主体性ってさ要は何したいのってこと
でしょ簡単に言えば人はしたいことには
主体性持ってるんだから何したたいのって
聞いてみたらいいよね本当にしたいこと何
と何の制約もなかったら何したいこれ1番
ね本人の主体性を引き出す質問だと思うん
だよで何したいって言った時に
ちょっとどうでしょうとかってこう詰まる
人っているじゃん結局今1番関心がある
ことってどんなことまカウンセリング的な
アプローチになるよねこれはだ人はあの5
つの基本的欲求によって動かされてる
じゃん生存の欲求愛と所属の欲求力の欲求
自由の欲求楽しみの欲求この欲求の中で
この人はどの欲求が1番強いんだろう
かっていうのをこう頭に置きながら色々
質問してみるといいんだよね中にはね願望
に向かって生きるタイプともう1つは責任
感で
頑張るタイプっているんだよだ必ずしも
願望が明確になってなかったとしても与え
られた役割を貫通している自分その責任を
果たしている自分そういうところに自分の
こう価値観を見出して頑張るタイプもいる
んだよねだからその前向きな願望だけに
焦点当てるんではなくてどういう自分で
ありたいのかっていう自然体で考えた時
にっていう質問してあげ
てその中でじゃあそれを成し遂げるために
どんな風に今自分ができることってどんな
ことがあると思うで質問をしていく上から
教えるというよりも引き出していく方が
大事だと思うな僕は割とどちらかというと
質問を使いますあのだ質問はいいんだけど
質問になっちゃだめようん詰めちゃだめよ
ねうんだからこう質問しながらま自由回答
型質問って言うんだけどAかBかどっちが
いいとかって言うとどっちかってこう閉鎖
型になるんで何の制約もなかったら何をし
たいってのはすごい解放的な質問じゃん
それとか今仕事のねやりがいだとか
働きがいだとかを今自分なりにどういう
ところに仕事の面白さを感じてるのとか
具体的に聞いてあげるってはすごく大事だ
よねそんな中からあのイメージが少しずつ
絞られてくるってこがあるんじゃないかな
ありがとうございますなんかこう質問して
も回答が出てこない人とかっていうのも
いらっしゃるのかなと思ったりするんです
けどなんかそういう時ってなんかどう
関わっていくないんです
[音楽]
かま山登りを例に取るとね自分でこの山
まず登りたいかどうかとで登りたいと思っ
たとしたら自分で登山計画立ててこらん僕
が考えた登山計画通りってもし途中で
大怪我したら納得いかないじゃんだから
自分なりに装備だとかどういう風に計画を
して調するのか一度自分なりにプラン立て
てみたらいいと思うよ同じだと思うんだっ
て仕事も主体的に自分なりの仕事のやり方
っていうのをまぜね計画を立ててみて
くれるという風にプランニングを出して
もらったらいいと思う本人にプランを考え
てもらうま要は考えさせるってことだよね
究極ね自ら考え自ら行動しその自ら考え
自ら行動したことには責任が伴うのでそれ
は人を育てることになるんですよところが
支持したことしかやらない支持したことを
実行するということにまある意味で慣れて
しまってるってことは主体性がないのでし
待ち人間になっちゃうじゃんそうすると
将来性がないよなうんま目指すべきものは
こういうことでいつまでにこういう成果を
作りたいと思ってるみんなでこの
プロジェクトを成功させたいと思うので
それぞれの立場でプロジェクト成功させる
ためのプランをみんなでちょっと揉んで
みようよっという風にして
自由に発言させながら3人とか4人で議し
ながら一緒になってプランを考えてみると
そのプランには参画してるわけだからそう
いう方法もいいんじゃないかな1人で1対
1で出てこなかったらま複数にの場を作り
ながら仕組みの中でこう体性を引き出して
いくっていうイメそうあのねあの目標達成
型の人材と役割を貫通するタイプと人
それぞれなんだよで役割を与えられて
みんなでそれを成し遂げる方が楽しいって
いう人もいるからだから自分が立てた目標
自分の意思でそのパーソナル個人の力で
やっていくっていうタイプとまスポーツで
もあるじゃんチーム団体戦の方が力が出
るっていうかやっぱりこう自分の役割を
全頭して全体の勝利に貢献できたっていう
のは大きな喜びになるっていうことがある
よねれとみんなでやったっていうこうやっ
たっていう達成感なんて言うのかなその人
にはタイプがあると思いますまそういう
ことを大事にしてあげると角のノルマだと
か
目標から解放されて逆に言うとみんなで
これを成しとけていこうと逆に言うとそう
いう仲間で決めたことなんだからそれは
自らの意思でちゃんと守らなきゃっていう
主体性が出てくることも考えられるよね
うんそういうことって大事なんじゃないか
なうんありがとうございますついこう上司
が主体性を求める時にやっぱ自分と同じ
タイプのその主体性をやっぱりこう求め
がちというかなんか1人でこう結果を出す
のが好きな上司だとやっぱりこうみんな
でっていうところのモチベーションに
そもそも気づかなかったりすることとかっ
てあるんじゃないかなと思ってですで
なんかその自分と違うタイプうんの人たち
のモチベーションのこう湧き方だったり
主体性の発揮の仕方になんか気づけ
るってどうやったら気づけるんですかね
[音楽]
うん自分と人とは違うという大前提をまず
持つことだよねま遺伝子も違えば育った
環境も違うし親も違うし兄弟も違うしそれ
からま成長過程でいろんな経験をしてくる
んだけど
その学習のプロセスも違うじゃんだけどま
ね何らかの縁があって会社に入ってきて
一緒に働くようになるわけだよねだから
その時にま参考になるのはね音楽の世界だ
と思います楽団やっぱり学風をみんな持っ
てその学風に対して忠実にやってくじゃん
だそういうものをやっぱり与えてあげ
るっていうのは上司の役割じゃないかと
思うねだから学府も何もない中で
とりあえず頑張ってとかそういう曖昧な
指導っていうのはやめた方がいいよね
使える資源はこれで役割はあなたの役割は
これでそれから記述もいつまでにこれを
成し遂げなければいけない一応その
プロジェクトはねそれぞれの役割はこう
いう役割でで中間チェックで一応こういう
進捗を確認しましょうと朝の何時から何時
までこのプランニングで一応進捗は
チェックしたいと思いますこれで遅れた
場合には誰々さんがカバーに入るような
こんなプランでいいですかってでみんなで
コンセンサスを取りながらまみんなでそれ
を進めていくうんそういう風にしていくと
いいんじゃないです
[音楽]
かまずは人は自分の都合では動かないので
やっぱりその目的目標を明確にしてあげる
手助けをするということと目的目標を明確
にしたら次は具体的なプランニングをそれ
は個人でにおいても全体においてもやぱ
プランをしっかりと計画だよね目標達成の
手順方法内容を一緒に共有しながらあとは
進捗管理だと思うんですよそれを毎日の
チェックをしっかりしながらみんなでここ
まで来たねっていう風に進めていったらま
個人のやる気に依存するプロジェクト
マネージメントではなくてやっぱり
きちっとした達成に導いていける
プロジェクト管理ができるんじゃないかと
思うけどま非常にねえ大切なあの仕事の
進め方だと思います是非今日のね私の今の
メッセージを聞いて私はこんな風にして
ますよとか今のことすご参考になりました
よとかなんかコメント欄にあれば是非
コメントお願いしますあとチャンネル登録
まだの方是非チャンネル登録もよろしくお
願いしたいと思い
ます貧しいということは人に対して価値を
提供することができていなかった結局僕の
人生というのは良い情報との出によって
良い人生になったということなんですよ
青木サの人生系鉄学100回聞いたら豊か
になる
話それでは青木サスの人生系哲学100回
聞いたら豊かになる話スタートしてまいり
ます青木社長今回ついに第100話目で
ございますはいよく続きましたいやいや
本当にありがとうございますで今回ですね
ま100話目ということでまここまでこの
YouTubeチャンネルうんのテーマも
100回聞いたら豊かになる話ということ
でまお届けしてまいりましたけれども
改めてま本当にどうしたら人はまよりよく
豊かな人生を生きることができるのかと
いうことについて今回は是非ですね青木
社長からメッセージをいただきたいと思っ
ておりますなるほど
[音楽]
ま僕も本当に貧しかったからね社会だ時は
ねうんまともかく貧しいということは結論
は人に対して価値を提供することができて
いなかったま社会に出た時は自分自身の
考え方にしても持ってる知識にしても持っ
ている技術技能にしても人のために大きな
力になることはできなかったまそれが17
歳の鉄構上で溶接子を見習いとして
スタートした第1歩ですよねそしてその後
ま喫茶店の防衛もやりましたし別にその
職業に規制はないんだけれどもいろんな
仕事を経験していく中で良い人と出会いが
ありそしてま私はそのチャンスを生かした
よねで特に僕は営業の世界ででチャンスを
もにして適正もあったのかもしれないけど
もま誰にも負けない努力をしようという
ことで本当によく頑張ったと思います自分
でもねでまトップセルスマンになりそして
トップセールスマネージャーを目指しま
そこでまた自分なりの思考を現実化させま
そして29歳の時に縁があって開発の
コンサル会社に入りまそこで私は今度は
セルスセルスマネジメントでえ培った経験
を生かしてまその
会社の組織をま売上を3年で7倍にする
ことができて32歳で創業をしたわけです
よねでも32歳で創業した時は資本金
500万社員5名独立しない時の方が
収入も多かったし独立前の方がステータス
も僕は持ってたと思うんですよまでも
チャレンジをしてジジ達成という社名の
会社を作ったわけですよねま色々トライ
アンドエラーをし
ながら選択理論という心理学を世の中に
広め成光
哲学Sアグローリッチの考え方を世の中に
広めまそれもトレーニングプログラムに
よって今日まで37年間ま私も1
トレーナーとしても現役でずっとやり続け
て今も3日間の研修をやっています決して
お金を追ってきた人生ではないんですよお
金はあくまでもバロメーターでしかあり
ません今の自分の行き方はですね多くの
先人の残してくださった言葉や本当に書物
色々脳に入れた情報によって私は自分の
考え方を作っていきましたま結局僕の人生
というのは良い情報との出会いによって
良い人生になったということなんですよ
今回のYouTubeの中でも100本の
中で成功者と達成者の違いということも私
は伝えてるんですけどなんで今自分自身
健康で良好な人間関係家族家庭生活も本当
にありがたいほど恵まれてますし2人の子
はもう企業もしま職業としても私はまあ
日本を代表する能力発コンサルタントに
なりたいと思って努力をしてきてま一応
公開講座では今アーメントという会社は
日本一のポジションになってると思うん
ですよねで経済も安定してで人生も楽しん
でますどうしてそうなれたん
だろうおそらくそれは僕は信じたからだと
思います人はその人が考えていた通りの
人間になるあるナイチンエールの言葉です
よね人はいつからでもどこからでも良く
なれる諦めない人生に終わりはない私は
29歳の時にバイブルと出会いました夏目
史郎先生の導きででそのバイブルの中に何
があったかとま新約聖書の方ですよね人生
で1番大切なものは何かと愛なんですよ
この愛を土台に愛を熟に愛を人生の中心に
おいて
ま不完全だ
けど目的はやっぱり縁ある人を幸せにし
たいとこれはやっぱり豊かな心だと思っ
てるんですねというのはずっとたどると
やっぱり夏目史郎先生私の恩師夏目史郎
先生に言われた言葉が暗示のように僕を
動かしてると思います青木君豊かな人生
よりは
豊かな人間になることを求めなさいなぜ
なら豊かな人間こそが豊かな人生を生きる
ことができるからだよとじゃ豊かな人間
って何だろうって言うとやっぱり与える
ことのできる人間だと思うんだよねだ
与えるためには持たなければならないので
だから僕はまず持とうとしましたセールス
ならセールスでやっぱり技術を持たないと
教えられないもんマインドノウハウスキル
で身につけたでそれを教えて僕はまた今度
はマネージャーとして1番1番になっ
たってことは結果1番なんでその教えた
ことが効果的だったってことなんだろうな
そして今僕はトレーナーになって49人の
方々にメッセージをしが開発した3日間の
研修プログラムもすでに新規受行生が私が
直接伝えただけじゃなくて弟子が伝えた
ことも合わせてもう6万人以上の人に
伝わってるわけですよね結局何を伝えてき
たかって言うと愛を土台にした真の成功の
生き方を伝えてきたんですよそれは5つの
基本的欲求が満たされる日々を送りましょ
うっていうことなんですよだ究極は毎日
毎日の1日一生なんですよ満足した1日1
日の積み重ねが人生なんですよ毎日豊かに
生きるってことだと思うんですよそれは
大金持ちになったら豊かになれるわけじゃ
なくて毎日豊かに生きることによって
結果大金持ちにもなれるっていうことだと
思うんだよね私は今毎月1回経営者を対象
に理念経営ということを教えてますで私の
67冊の著書の中で経営者は人生理念作り
から始めなさいっていう本まこの本をまず
課題図書で読んでもらってアチーブメント
ピラミッドの一貫性を持って生き
るっていうことでまその土台に私の場合は
愛と誠実と感謝という三心情をおいてそれ
を日々の実践の中で毎日どう表現できるか
と生きてるわけですけれどもお金を追う
わけでもなく地位を負うわけでもなく名誉
を負うわけでも
なくまさにこの行のように一貫性を追求し
てるだけなんですよで僕はあの人からの
評価って全く気にしないんだよねねだから
人からよく思われたいという気持ちは捨て
た方がいいと
思ううんその気持ちがある時はねまだね
本当の豊かさじゃないんだよねあの人から
認められたくて頑張るっていうのは誰か
からの愛の喪失の恐怖につがるんです
よ人から認められたくて頑張るというのは
評価が第3者になるんだよね自分じゃ
なくなっちゃうんですよそうじゃなくて
自分で納得できる毎日を生きるってこと
なんです
よそしたら自分が評価してるからお前よく
やったってサトシお前よく生きてるよって
懸命に生きてるよね頑張ってるよね僕は
すんごい自分が大好きになりましたそう
いう生き方をしていく自分
が社会で時は全然自分のこと好きじゃ
なかった
結局僕は
物心共に豊かな人生
を生きることができるようになったんです
よまだまだこんなもんじゃないですどんな
ものなのかと私の向上心まで私は伸びてき
ますだからなんだろう人からどう思われる
かとか人と比べるというのはもう本当
くだらないと思ってますだ僕はね実はした
ことないしもうブリタニカの時に達成者に
なってトロフィー本当にねいっぱいもらい
ましたでもあれ引っ越しするためにゴミな
のよプラスチックのあのトロフィーって
引っ越しするために捨てちゃったようん
いや金のねなんかバッチぐらいはね思い出
に持ってるよいくつかあたほとんど全部
捨てたね心の中にはありますやり切った
自分すんごい働いた僕大好きですだ結局
豊かな人生
って自分自身を承認できる人生なんじゃ
ないのかなそれは人から与えられるもん
じゃなくて自分の生き方で作り出すもんな
んじゃないのかなちょっと長くなったけど
そんな風に思うけど
[音楽]
ねシンプルに言えば物心ともに豊かな人生
だから経済的にも精神的にも豊かである
ってことでしょでそれプラス健康である
こと愛に満たされている人生もっと言うと
本当に人を愛する
自由こう愛せる自分僕人を愛せる自分が
大好きですがやっぱり職業で多くの人から
ありがとうっていう言葉をたくさんもらっ
てる状態なんじゃないのいつもありがと
うっていうどれだけありがとうイコール
喜んでもらってるかけがいない存在として
あなたにはこれからもずっと存在していて
欲しいって思われているっていうのは
すごく大切なことじゃないかなその鍵はね
過去の犠牲者にならないってことなんです
よ過去は最善なんです人は確かに過去の
産物ではあるが自らが選択しない限り
決して過去の犠牲者になることは
ないこれは私どもの最高顧問だった
ウィリアムグラッサーの言葉です僕も
決して優等生じゃなかったんですよ若い時
はでもそこで学習して今があるわけですよ
だから無駄はないんですよ何1つだその
過去に縛られるんではなく今を生きるこれ
がやっぱり心の解放ということなんじゃ
ないかなだからまそういう意味では自分と
未来は変えられるけど他人と過去は変え
られないというこれを本当に深いレベルで
理解して日々できることに焦点を当てて
最善を尽くして生きてるところに責任ある
生き方の中に自由があるんじゃないかと
思うしまそういう意味では自己訓練自己
検算を積み上げるってのは大事だと思い
ますあとは楽しむってことでしょ
思いっきり楽しむってことだと思う人生は
僕はもう健康麻雀もやるしね共同主で別に
書けことしないのであの馬券も買うわけで
はないんだけどま仲間とねそういう良い
コミュニティ作ったりクラシックカーも僕
はやるしすごく車も好きだしなんだ
キャンピングカーも持ってたりなんだろ
人生を楽しむよねだから金持って死ぬって
いうことを考えてないです
だから財団に最後はかなりの額捧げる
つもりですで自分が死んだ後も小学金が
ずっと出せる財団は残るこれは個人は
有限組織は無限ですだから青木サ教育財団
これは私が死んだ後も心ざしのある人が
この財団をずっと守ってくれて毎年
アーメンが発展し続てる間そこからの配当
それを奨学金として出し
続けるまさか溶接込み習いで社会だこんな
こと考える人間になるとは思わなかった
なあ不思議だねだからやっぱりうん求めよ
さらば与えられん
うんありがとうございますって感じかな
いや僕本当にねこの100話まで
YouTubeをね見てくれている人に心
から感謝し
ます1話から全部見てくれてる人いるんだ
もんいつも見てますよとかありがたいよね
本当にありがたいま100話で終わりでは
ありません俺やめないよこんな楽しいこと
なんでやめなきゃいけないもうやっぱり
喜んでもらってるもんもう迷惑だって言わ
れたらやめるようんでも迷惑だって言わ
れるまではやるよそうでしょうんだって
目的は自分が豊かになったら自分だけの
ものにしないで他の人に分かち合うといや
こんな素晴らしい手段があると思わなかっ
たねあ
本当ありがたいよ
ね無償でねありがたいよねありがたい
ありがたいありがたいいやともかくねこの
システムを誰が考えたか分からないけどま
Googleの人なんだろうけど
ありがたいよやもって言うとねこの話で
サポートしてくれた戸田さんありがとう僕
の友人です戸田さん戸田佐藤さん
ありがとうそしてこの
プロデューサー赤島早期そして今僕の目の
前にいる岡口ねみんな力貸してくれた本当
にそしてさんとこのスタッフのね方々も
ありがたい感謝感謝感謝うんまそういう
ことですありがとうございます是非またえ
チャンネル登録もよろしくお願いします
そしてえできたらねま今日初めての方はえ
チャンネル登録もよろしくお願いしたいと
思いますしコメントもたくさんください
それではありがとうございますまず100
話これで終わりますありがとうございまし
た人はいつからでもどこからでも良く
なれる諦めない人生に終わりはない